[Music]
Dwyane Wade and Jimmy Butler in a Jersey
extreme to former Marquette currents
[Applause]
[Music]
now there never will be another Dwyane
Wade a once-in-a-lifetime player who has
had a storybook end to his amazing 16
season NBA career have never seen a star
go out with this much love and fanfare
how about this impromptu team photo
right at MIT cool that is really cool
they are all trading jerseys and tanks
to answer
Hank Henry Thomas Dwayne's beloved
longtime agent who passed away a couple
years ago but has never left the heart
or the memory of Dwayne
what a class sack celebrating with his
team hates right there including them
all along the way
[Music]
this game could not have played out in a
better way for Maya when he twin at 122
299 it turned out to be a victory lap
for Twain weighed in his final game at
home and really cool to see you tennis
hassle enjoy 11 minutes of
fourth-quarter playing time and as I
hear in Twain father and son
Oh Monica do it the only way I know how
y'all
that was tragic let's try it again
let's do it this way all right
as simple as this way County I love you
luckily I bought a lot